[Música]
sabe aquela idéia fantástica que vocês
têm o guardado na gaveta que tem tudo
para dar certo mas faltou um
detalhezinho de nada pois ano
e aí antes mesmo de pensar em alguma
coisa ou como que isso vai surgir ou
como materializar essa ideia se volta
para sua vida superfrustrado se sentindo
muito útil e deixando aquela grande
ideia de lado
eu tenho certeza que isso já aconteceu
muitas vezes com muitos de vocês aqui eu
sei porque isso acontecer direto comigo
quando era mais novo eu queria muito
fazer um site para mim quando era mais
moleque mas eu não entendia nada de
código
eu queria ser um designer muito melhor
do que eu era mas eu não sabia como é
que chegava nesses resultados tão legais
que eu via nos anuários e nas revistas
eu queria muito ter minha própria
empresa mas eu não tinha a menor noção
como uma empresa funcionando que era de
r e fluxo de caixa essas coisas e eu
acho que isso acontece isso um algum de
vocês até hoje a única coisa que posso
dizer parabéns estão a um passo de se
tornar aquele som e eu não tô falando
daqueles caras que invada em conta e
vazam informações e causam prejuízo
estou falando de gente que pensa fora da
caixinha que independente do método
resolve o que precisa ser resolvido que
buscam soluções que podem ser malucas
mas que funciona um
eu me considero um hacker hoje o meu
trabalho é tornar possível colocar de pé
projetos que parecem impossíveis
e aí quando falo isso as pessoas falam
pô como assim né
é eu trabalho com o projeto de realidade
virtual à realidade aumentada e
instalações artísticas tão bem ali no
cruzamento entre a criatividade ea
tecnologia
a maioria das vezes quando começa um
desses projetos não têm a menor noção
como eles vão ficar até o final de
simplesmente porque eles nunca foram
feitos mas eu aprendi a pegar esses
desafios super complexos e colocar eles
dividido em pequenas tarefas que brahim
desafios menores aparecendo como isso é
como se fosse um videogame sabe a gente
vai passando de fase acumulando
vidas acumulando poderes para no final
do jogo enfrentar o recopa
só que nesse caso as vidas são os erros
e acertos durante o projeto os poderes
aqueles parceiros incríveis que vão te
ajudar e o recopa o projeto entregue e
aí muita gente me pergunta mas você fez
faculdade cara que pouco como se tudo
estivesse fazendo hoje eu tivesse
aprendido na escola mas não é bem assim
tá é só para registrar o fez publicidade
numa época que a rede social ainda o
orkut eo iphone nem existe ainda
eu era um cara super focado em off line
eu gostava de impressos gostava das
revistas de design gráfico e eu acho que
aprendi muita coisa legal na faculdade
eu tenho certeza que a educação formal
até hoje tem o seu valor
o rh da empresa que você trabalha também
acho e até às vezes sem saber porquê mas
não é à toa que a maioria das 100 das
vagas de trabalho que pagam bem tem como
pré-requisito superior completo
mas sendo bem sincero 90% do que eu faço
hoje eu aprendi correndo atrás indo além
buscando informação onde eu não
encontrava ou em livros ou em vídeos e
revistas autoriais e a principal
modificação para mim nessa nessa corrida
toda é que eu entendi a diferença entre
ter uma carreira
o modelo y e uma carreira de modelo t
não sei se estão familiarizadas com o
assunto
mas só pra passar rapidinho uma carreira
y em dado momento da sua trajetória você
tem que escolher entre seguir um caminho
seguir outro ser um cara mais técnico
mas o especialista ou então se um gestor
mais generalista administrando o
trabalho que você sabe fazer mas que
outras pessoas vão fazendo no modelo de
carreira tempo a gente vai acumulando
pequenas doses de conhecimento mas vai
se aprofundando em algumas que são o
nosso o nosso centro
então independente do problema que vem o
desafio que aconteça você vai ter muito
mais bagagem pra entregar isso aí tem um
relatório muito bacana no fórum
econômico mundial eles lançam de tempos
em tempos que chama fitch nove jogos o
sport é as principais tendências de como
os principais líderes do mundo enxergam
como é que está o futuro do trabalho e
duas que me chamaram muita atenção nesse
último para 2022 eles falam que a
aprendizagem ativa ou seja a nossa
capacidade de continuar aprendendo e
criatividade a nossa capacidade de usar
o que a gente aprendeu em qualquer outro
canto
são as principais valorizadas para 2022
ao mesmo tempo que eu acho que é fazer
planilhas ou saber usar determinado
software não vai ser tão valorizado
assim
isso porque a gente está terceirizando
saber e automatizando tarefas para
máquinas
a gente não precisa mais saber coisas
super complexas como trigonometria por
exemplo é mas se eu precisar eu sei
aonde buscar ou aprendeu rapidinho
buscar um especialista nisso pra me
ajudar
a gente está entrando em uma era que é
muito mais importante ter uma visão do
todo ampla e agir rápido do que
simplesmente ser um especialista num
campo som eu vou chamar essa era de era
dos polímatas polímata são pessoas que
têm talentos diversos que podem ou não
ser complementares e eles usam quando
necessário um bom exemplo a leonardo da
vinci esse cara era um problema da nato
ele ao mesmo tempo era incrível em
pintura escultura e tinha trabalhos
fantásticos de engenharia e arquitetura
o steve jobs foi considerado polímata do
nosso tempo ele trilhou soluções
incríveis na área de design e tecnologia
entretenimento e pessoalmente o meu
polímata favorito e romance que ele não
só é o fundador da empresa super
discutidas como a tesla motors ea spacex
mas ele também se envolve diretamente
nessas soluções
a gente não precisa mais ser só uma
coisa ou outra a gente atenção ao rótulo
a gente pode ter
se várias coisas de vários talentos e
usar eles quando for necessário
dois anos atrás eu estava com minha
esposa marketing e vivendo naquela
comunidade fantástica de alunos
incríveis professores fantásticos
eu aprendi um conceito que mudou minha
vida num todo mundo aqui já ouviu falar
de multidisciplinar certo quando a gente
tem
vários indivíduos com especialidades
diferentes
é trabalhando em conjunto um lado mas eu
aprendi um negócio que chama ante
disciplinar e não é que não tem
disciplina nenhuma a galera não é uma
[ __ ] bagunça mas é quando a gente reúne
profissionais para trabalhar em
conceitos que não são disciplinas ainda
então vamos porque a gente pega e
colocar na mesma sala o agrônomo um
designer o engenheiro mecânico para
pensar em colonização sustentável em
outros planetas
a gente não tem ainda livros que falam
sobre agricultura em marte ou
arquitetura em gravidade zero ou até
como programar o seu robô para cozinhar
proteína ver gana mas se a gente não
pensar em equipe santista plenárias
jamais vai acontecer
ok vocês estão falando bom beleza sequer
foi longe né
tem que voltar para a terra falar de
coisas mais práticas como é que eu vi
onde disciplinar um hacker um polímata e
calma é esse depende muito mais esforço
de vocês vocês podem imaginar
mas não é uma simples chave de liga e
desliga senão vira hacker da noite pro
dia assim como ninguém vira atleta
olímpico da noite pro dia gradativamente
vai aprendendo
acho que o principal a mentalidade que a
gente possa mudar que normalmente a
gente tem é do eu não sou bom nisso eu
não tenho talento pra isso mas como eu
eu não sou bom nisso ainda dá pra você
aprender e aprimorar qualquer tarefa
ninguém aqui nessa sala nasceu sabendo
andar sabendo falar sabendo escrever ou
fazer de toque mas tudo isso foi
apreendido
gradativamente a gente foi dos nossos
primeiros passos
mexendo a boca tentando falar fazendo um
monte de coaching e aí deu certo
gradativamente a gente vai sair da nossa
zona de conforto
tem um monte de toque falando em zona de
conforto vídeos tutoriais livros têm um
nome que eu adoro isso aqui você tem
digo a sua zona de conforto e de fato
onde há mágica a inovação acontecem
e para você sair de um lugar e ir para o
outro sair da zona de conforto para onde
a mágica acontece em uma parada chama
motivo
sam sabe aquele filme de sessão da tarde
o time está perdendo de lavada e aí
entra uma pessoa x no vestiário faz
aquele [ __ ] discurso legal tal fica todo
motivado e aí galera entra e vence a
motivação tem muito a ver com isso tem a
ver com achar o momento certo e um
propósito claro se esse discurso toda
aconteceu no começo talvez não fizesse
tanto sentido porque não estava claro
ainda o propósito né pessoal não estava
tão decepcionado
para vocês terem um exemplo mais prático
na década de 60 os estados unidos tinha
como principal motivação botar o homem
na lua não provar que isso era possível
mas recuperar o orgulho nacional que
eles estavam perdendo uma corrida para
união soviética um tempão atrás já
naquela época o presidente john kennedy
fez um discurso fantástico chama o tio
chegou todo mundo nós escolhemos ir para
a lua e além de ser super motivador ele
estabelece uma meta de no máximo 10 anos
eles vão botar o homem na lua e sete
anos depois de o hamas não estava lá
dando a primeira pegada no solo né
mas ok eu apanho o espaço de novo né
trazendo um exemplo mais próximo que não
demora dez anos
eu tenho um amigo do caio e ele fez um
projeto super bacana que chama 30 dias
30 projetos
ele tinha que criar intervenções urbanas
com os amigos dele que refletissem a
nossa interação com a tecnologia do dia
a dia com uma regrinha básica
ele tinha uma ação por dia durante 30
dias
basicamente em um mês ele conseguiu
fazer 30 projetos e testar o que davi
não dava pra fazerem sim mês não só eles
conseguiram fazer um portfólio super
bacana são todos publicitários tal mas
eles conseguiram também terá atenção da
mídia o que foi mais legal ainda pra
eles porque era super importante que
eles criassem esse burburinho
ultimamente a minha motivação principal
tem sido o desafio eu constantemente
tome desafiando falando eu duvido pra
mim mesmo e através desse desafio que eu
lanço eu sempre busco
um prazo que eu tenho para cumprir esse
desafio eu pego um marco no calendário
de trás pra frente envolvendo o que eu
posso fazer para criar isso aqui sou eu
ano passado fazendo o meu sofá
ano passado eu decidi que eu ia fazer
pelo menos metade da mobília da minha
casa
a gente estava voltando dos estados
unidos para cá não sei se desafio tinha
dois meses livres de começar a trabalhar
e eu fiz não só sofá mas os móveis da
sala da cozinha à cabeceira da cama
enfim
infelizmente a minha esposa não brigou
muito comigo mas gradativamente foi
quebrando esse desafio em o que é fazer
um sofá como é trabalhar com madeira
quais são os tipos de acabamento
quais são as coisas que eu preciso usar
e eu fui projetando aprendendo a usar as
ferramentas até ter o meu sofá quentinho
que está lá na minha casa me esperando
eu acho que se eu consigo fazer isso
qualquer um aqui nessa sala consegue
deve ter um plano infalível que vocês
queiram botar em prática alguma coisa
que está guardada na gaveta um tempão e
que vocês deixaram de lado por algum
motivo pode ser aprender um idioma novo
pintar parede do quarto entrar numa
roupa que não cabe mais ou até fazer
sofá e normalmente a gente se coloca
muita desculpa pra isso né
muita coisa que a gente acaba falando
pra nós mesmos porque a gente não
consegue então assim a todos e não tenho
tempo sem grana eu tô cansado pior de
todas elas eu não tenho jeito para isso
ela era ninguém tem jeito pra nada mas a
gente dá um jeito para tudo sejam
hackers busquem uma solução que está
fora da caixinha vai pra onde a mágica
acontece pega o calendário e marcam uma
data
essa data vai ser só data de entrega
vamos dizer assim vai ser seu prazo
através desse prazo vai começar a olhar
o calendário de trás pra frente e vai
ver o que você pode fazer pra concluir
essa tarefa
lembra das fases do videogame é mais ou
menos isso
cada uma dessas fases vão ser as suas
pequenas vitórias vamos dizer sim a um
psicólogo americano que chama isso de
pequenas vitórias e elas têm um papel
fundamental porque quando a gente prova
para nós mesmos que nós somos capazes
é meio que é o o energético natural que
a gente precisa pra ir pra frente
então eu queria aproveitar o dia de hoje
e lançar um desafio pra vocês até o
final do dia ou até a manhã de amanhã é
de vocês pensarem em algum desses
projetos que ficou lá atrás esquecido o
que você tem muita vontade de fazer ea
partir de saber qual esse projeto
você sabe depois o que você tem que
fazer a partir disso tenta quebrar em
pequenos desafios de ordem cronológica e
tudo mais para que dê certo pensa que um
videogame ou não vocês já têm questão
fazer para transformar isso em sin piano
[Aplausos]
[Música]